a binary tree is a common data structure
used in software development it's also a
frequent topic in technical coding
interviews in this course alvin will
explain binary tree algorithms and
prepare you to use them in both
interviews and coding projects
hey programmers i'm alvin from structe
welcome to our course on binary trees i
want to show you how you can do well on
those technical interviews that have
binary tree problems so what i have in
store for this course like usual we'll
go over both the theory behind some
binary tree algorithms as well as of
course be more practical and come up
with the code to implement those
algorithms so really a one-two punch for
every section we're going to be sure to
draw a lot of pictures and visualize and
truly understand the algorithm on the
whiteboard now once we're feeling
comfortable with that we'll go over to
the code implementation so in the
description and in the timestamps you'll
be able to find the corresponding
exercise where you can practice every
algorithm that we go over in terms of
the prerequisites for this course i'm
going to assume that you're you know not
new to programming and maybe you've
dabbled in some previous data structures
and algorithms and you're also familiar
with some recursion now that being said
i'm going to assume you know nothing
about binary trees and even just trees
in general now with no further ado let's
jump right in
so first order of business is let's
actually understand what the word tree
even means in like the programming
concept right so when we visualize a
tree a tree contains many nodes
typically we draw nodes as circles right
and these nodes can also point to other
nodes so here i have one node and it
could point to some other node right it
could point to any number of nodes so
here are the circles i'm going to refer
to them as nodes and the lines or hours
between them i'm going to call edges
right and so this is an example of a
tree and trees can of course come in
many different shapes and sizes so
here's quite a large tree
let's try to understand a few terms we
can use during our technical interviews
and this is something i highly recommend
right helps if you speak the language it
does show that you have proficiency
dealing with the data structure
we could store values within the nodes
of our tree for now i'm just going to
put some letters
when it comes to your programs you can
store any type you want you can store
integers numbers or even other objects
so because we have a tree we like to use
familial relationships in other words i
think of like a family tree right so if
i look at node b let's say i call them
the parent
if b is the parent i know that children
of b are just the d and e nodes right
right parent and child is like a
relative relationship
let's say i kind of changed my frame of
reference and let's say i looked at a as
the parent well in that scenario then b
and c are the children of a right for
the case of the c note if i think of c
as some parent it only has one child its
lone child being the f node so feel free
to use that parent-child relationship
when describing the relationship among
nodes within a tree
another term we'll use a lot in the
context of trees is the word root right
so a root is going to be a node that has
no parent so in this tree a is the root
because a has no parent right there are
no arrows going into the a node
on the flip side of that if i look at
the nodes d e and f we call them leaf
nodes a leaf node is a node that has no
children right so d and f have no
outgoing arrows
typically in a binary tree we're going
to have a single root we could have many
leaves
one thing you'll want to be sure to do
is make sure you generalize your
understanding of a leaf right so in this
particular example looks like every leaf
is two edges away from the root counting
the number of arrows from the root to
any leaf it could be the case that my
leaves occur at different levels right
so i removed that f node in which case c
is now a leaf right although a c is on
like a different level then d and e it's
not at the bottom most level it is the
case that it's still a leaf right a leaf
node is just a node that has zero
children all right so with all of those
terms out of the way now let's hone in
on the real topic here right i talked a
lot about trees but really in this
course i want to go over the basics of
binary trees right so let's look at that
binary part to begin with that's really
a dead giveaway renault binary has to do
with the number two
a binary tree is a tree where every node
has at most two children right so
currently on the screen i have a binary
tree
if i gave a another child let's say a
third note over here of f this would be
a tree but not a binary tree right it
would be like a ternary tree because i
have at most three children
so let's say i kind of removed that
extra node now it's back to a binary
tree
and it could be the case that a node has
less than two children but still be a
binary tree right so if i give c just a
child of f this is still a binary tree
so if i look at any node within my tree
that node will have 0 one or two
children and no one has more than two
children right so you want to be sure to
remember that a node in a binary tree
could have less than two children
all right so that'll be the first
criteria for understanding what a binary
tree is right it's probably the easiest
criteria at most two children per node
we'll also want to be sure to add into
our definition to have a robust
understanding is to also remember that
at least for us in computer science we
think of our binary trees as having
exactly one root meaning there should be
only a single node that has no parent
right typically when we draw it it would
be like the topmost node so right now
this is definitely so far a binary tree
if i had some other node in this drawing
like g right g also has no parents i
would no longer consider this a classic
binary tree right so watch out for that
let's go on to our final criteria we
also need one more ingredient and that's
exactly one path between the root and
any node right so looking at my example
to the left this is indeed a binary tree
that meets all three criteria now let's
say i chose the root and any node
obviously there's only one root so we're
definitely considering the a node let's
say i chose some random node like e if
this is really a binary tree then we're
guaranteed to have only a single path
that connects a to e a path is really
just a series of connected nodes i can
travel through right so to get from the
root a to the node e i can go from a to
b to e and that would be one path and
that's the only way to get from a to e
that's what i mean by exactly one path
let's say i chose another node like f
there is also exactly one way to get
from the root to f and that's just acf
that would be the only path
if i added some additional connections
or edges within my tree i can get a
scenario like this this would no longer
be a binary tree for one we can see that
b has three children but also does not
have a unique path between the root and
any node for example if i chose the root
of a and the node of f one way to get
there is by going acf but another way to
get there would be a b c f
right
and so do watch out for all three
criteria when you're considering a
binary tree
awesome so let's look at some smaller
examples and this is where i think some
students tend to struggle with their
understanding of binary trees so if i
took out some nodes over here this would
definitely still be a binary tree right
just looking at our different rules
right let's say the root node a only had
one child it would still be a binary
tree right because a binary tree only
demands that we have at most two
children we still have one root and we
still have only one path from root to
any node let's say i have the smallest
tree that has a node which would be the
singleton tree this is still considered
a binary tree
right it has one root there's not really
any paths to be had here except the root
two itself and every node does have at
most two children here we have zero
children right
the final edge case i want to think
about is what happens when we have
no nodes right we consider this as the
empty tree this is a very special case
and we should consider any empty tree as
actually being a binary tree that's
going to be very useful when we come up
with some algorithms later on right so a
common edge case i'll have to consider
is what happens when we have an empty
tree that's a tree with zero nodes right
let's look at another example let's say
i had this structure so take a moment
look at it and see if this meets our
criteria
this would not be considered a binary
tree so if you look at your different
criteria looking at the first one it
does have at most two children per node
so that's okay but we can't identify
exactly one root here remember that a
root node is a node that has no parent
right if you look at every node in this
picture every node has exactly one in
going arrow so that means every node has
at least one parent right so it doesn't
meet that criteria
and furthermore there is not exactly one
path between the root and any node
because we have a cycle within the
structure so for example let's say i was
starting at a right and i wanted to
travel to c one way to get there would
be to go a
b
c that would be one path but i could
also have another path where i just go
around twice and go a
b
c again there would actually be an
infinite number of paths in this
scenario because of that this is
definitely not a binary tree and there
are kind of many reasons for that if i
had a different example looking at this
one
now i meet criteria one and two right i
have at most two children for every node
but i also still have exactly one root
node here i would consider z the root
node however there is not one path
between the root and any node and
because i have that cycle
so these rules are really worth
remembering they're really going to help
you solve a much more difficult binary
tree problems and if you remember these
three rules you can identify different
problems in a binary tree framework in
other words the hardest problems that
you'll encounter in your interviews are
problems where they don't tell you
straight up what data structure you're
dealing with you're just gonna have to
notice the pattern in other words what
if i gave you some structure like this
take a moment and figure out if this is
a binary tree
if you look closely this does meet all
of the three criteria to be a binary
tree i can just treat a as the root
because it has no parent i can treat
nodes d e and f as the leaves because
they have no children i just drew this
in a pretty interesting way right if you
rearrange things in a classical binary
tree sense it would look like this more
importantly this has the same
relationships as the previous drawing i
just drew it in a top down fashion right
so no matter what do you understand
these three rules for a binary tree
right because sometimes may not be as
explicit as a nice triangular shape
drawing
awesome so we talked a lot about the
theory of how to you know look at and
reason through some binary true
definitions let's go ahead and start to
talk about how we could represent a
binary tree programmatically in other
words how can we do this in some code
well no matter your programming language
of choice i think you're going to
represent these as objects in other
words every node here is going to be
some object so it could be like an
instance of a class
the properties only to store now within
this object would be the current value
so i need something to store like the a
of my current node but i also need to
refer to some children so i will also
need some left and right pointers to the
children right those are just going to
be some properties on that object
in a classic binary tree it is very
common to refer to the two children
using a left and right direction notice
that some nodes here like the c node
they're only going to have one child
right c only has a node.right it does
not have a left so we're gonna have to
use some empty value like null or
undefined to represent a child that
doesn't exist right especially for a
node like e e has no left and also no
right
so here's what we'll do let's go ahead
and hop into my text center and i'll
show you how you could represent a
binary tree programmatically so
transition here we are in my text editor
let's start by creating our node class
right so you'll be able to follow along
in any language that you choose i'm
going to do mine in javascript right so
i think the best way to present a node
is just to use some class so hopefully
familiar with some classic class syntax
i'll just create a node class
i'm just going to need a quick
constructor
and i think would be valuable to take in
the initial value that's going to be
stored within the node so i'll take that
in as a constructor argument
i can just set this.val to that value i
also need two more properties
one for my left so i can say this dot
left i'm going to initialize it to null
that means by default a node will have
no left child the same way by default a
node will have no
right child right so i'm going to use
null to represent children that don't
exist over here
awesome that's all you need to create
you know a baseline binary tree right
we're going to use this class a lot
during the course to test our algorithms
so how can you create a node and
eventually wire up a tree well i'll just
call my constructor a few times i'll
create different nodes i'll just throw
them into some variable names
and i'll of course say new node to
create a new instance of node and i'll
store some value inside i'm going to
store some characters inside
i'll create a bunch of these different
nodes
what we'll want to be sure to do is
make sure that you also set their
pointers properly so i'll give each of
these some different values a b c
d
e
also do f
and then i'll just manually for now
set their pointers properly
so what if i did syntax like this like
since i'm in javascript i can easily
assign these pointers i can say a's left
is going to be b
i can say a is right
is c
i can also say b's left is d
and then b's right is e and maybe
finally i can say
c's right is f
so by doing these assignments i'm
connecting some nodes together
i should end up with a structure like
this right have a as the root because
nothing points to a a has no parent
but a has two children
of b and c
and then along with that
b has two children
of d and e
finally c just has a right child
of f this is actually the same tree that
we looked at a lot during the whiteboard
session right and this is how you can
represent that same tree
programmatically right so i always think
it's valuable to also try to visualize
your trees right obviously we created
this tree in a very manual way probably
in the long run it'll create
applications to just maintain and create
trees dynamically during some input
but for now we'll start by creating all
of our trees in this very kind of static
way right and so with that now that we
have an understanding of how to
represent a binary tree let's go ahead
back to the whiteboard and i can show us
our very first algorithm
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over this depth first values
problem so this will be a good review of
the depth first traversal algorithm so
what do you want to do in this problem
well what we want to do is take in a
binary tree in particular your function
is going to take in the root of the
binary tree and just recall that given
the root node of a binary tree we know
that that node's going to have pointers
to its left and right children which may
point to other nodes however if let's
say a node does not have a left or right
child then its point is going to be set
to null so that's how i represent our
binary tree programmatically but for now
let's just stick to the visual
representation of our tree so for a
depth first traversal we could start
with the root note of a what we'll do is
we'll just add that to some collection
and we're going to have to maintain
these in a very particular order
then from there according to a depth
first traversal i could go to b
and here's where we make our really
important decision right we can either
go to c or d if i'm doing a depth first
traversal i need to go deeper in the
tree before i move laterally so that
means i go from b to d
then once i bottom out at d there's
nowhere deeper i can go from d and so
now i move laterally to the e node
and this pattern continues right i don't
have anything deeper from e so now i go
to c
and then from c i go to f
so this would be a depth first traversal
on this binary tree notice that it goes
a b d e c f and again the really
important characteristic is we must go
deeper in the tree until we can't
anymore and then we can go across the
tree
that being said how can we actually
manage to implement this algorithm
if you're familiar with depth first
traditionally then we know that it's
going to use a data structure like a
stack so let's get situated over here
so we'll trace through that again but
this time taking a really close look at
how we can use a stack to accomplish
that direct order
and so just recall that a stack is a
sequential data structure where we can
only add things to the top of the stack
and remove things from the top of the
stack so a really important
characteristic is we can't really insert
or remove elements from anywhere but the
top of the stack so when i add things to
the stack i always add it to the top
like this
when i remove things it's also from the
top like this
all right so when i begin this depth
first traversal algorithm i'm going to
start with the root node of a
and by default i really just take that
root node and i just store it on my
stack so it's the only thing on my stack
right now i'll use these rectangles
represent my different stack frames and
really in my program that would just
mean storing the actual instance of node
or some pointer to it
cool and then from there i actually
begin my main algorithm
so the main flow of a depth first
reversal will check if the stack is
empty right now the stack is not empty
because i have at least one element and
so what i do is i start by removing or
popping the top element of my stack so
i'm going to remove the a
and i'll label that as my current node
being explored and when something leaves
the stack then i can consider it being
visited right now so i need to list out
my values because that's the whole point
of this problem right so by now i've
just visited the a node at this point i
can look at that node's children now so
look at the a node in the tree and i see
that it has a b child on its left and a
c child on its right
and from there i push or add those two
children to my stack so i'm going to put
c first
and i put b afterwards
and notice if i push my right child
first followed by my left child that
makes it such that my left child's the
top of my stack which means that i would
hit them next
and that actually ends on my first
iteration of this depth first traversal
and now i ask that same question is my
stack empty it's not so i remove the top
of my stack
i'll call b my current which means i
could print it out or insert it into my
values list
nice from there i consider b's children
b has two children so i add them both i
push e
followed by pushing d
that ends that iteration
now something interesting happens my
stack is still not empty so i know i
remove the top so i call d my current i
add d to my list of values but if i look
at these children it actually has no
children right and so there's nothing to
add to the stack from here
and so technically i finished this
iteration
and now i still have stuff on my stack
so now i pop e off the top of my stack
same thing as before right i add e to my
values
e has no children so i'm done with that
iteration
finally i have c
i remove c from the stack and i print it
out in my values and then at this point
i see that the c node only has one child
so i'm just going to push the children
that exists so i would push the f node
onto my stack
and that's a really important thing to
remember when it comes to implementing
your depth first traversal you're going
to have to check if your children exist
before you add them to your stack and
now on the final final iteration we have
the f node we remove it from the stack
we add it to our list of values f has no
children and so
i finished this iteration and now my
stack is empty
and i would just exit right once the
stack is empty i know that i must have
traveled through the entire binary tree
so there we have it and we do get the
correct output over here so just by
using a stack and just obeying the rules
of the stack that is we push to the top
and remove from the top we will get the
correct order important thing to
remember is you should add your values
into your like values list whenever
something leaves the stack
that being said what can we say about
the time and space complexity of this
algorithm well it's actually a pretty
straightforward let's say we define n as
the number of nodes in this binary tree
then we can say that the time complexity
of this is o of n and why do i say that
well we're just going to add every node
eventually to our stack and that node's
also going to leave the stack exactly
once so it's not like we're double
visiting any of the nodes so i'm
guaranteed to just run in o of n steps
in a similar way we can see that the
space complexity is of n the only thing
we stored was really the stack which is
a linear data structure and we know that
we're not going to put ever more than n
things on the stack so overall we have a
linear time and space solution for this
depth first traversal problem all right
i think we have a good understanding
about the approach for a depth first
traversal now let's go ahead to the
walkthrough video and we'll implement
this one in a few ways together
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this depth first values problem
and so we're going to do here is really
just implement that same strategy that
we traced through in the approach video
pretty much to the t
and we'll start with the iterative
version and that means of course we will
solve this a one in two different ways
right we're going to solve it
iteratively first and then afterwards
we'll go ahead and solve it recursively
all right so let's jump right in over
here now like we said in the approach
video we know that the iterative version
really relies on us creating a stack
and for most of your programming
languages you can just go ahead and use
your like array data structure for that
so i'm going to use just a plain old
javascript array i'll go ahead and name
this one stack
and we can just use an array to
represent a stack as long as we stick to
two particular methods right i'm going
to use array push which adds to the end
of an array and also array pop which
removes from the end of the array as
well so i'm going to consider the end of
my array to represent the top of my
stack
cool what i'll go ahead and do is
initialize the stack with the root node
on top of it
nice then i can have my main loop for
the algorithm so we know that we need to
keep running the algorithm while there's
stuff on our stack so i can just check
while stack dot length is greater than
zero so while i have at least one
element on my stack there is some work
to be done here
now we'll step through a single
iteration of this algorithm we know that
we start an iteration by just removing
the top of our stack in other words
stack.pop in javascript that will also
return us the element that we just
removed so i'll call that my current
const current
and that is going to be an instance of
nodes it's going to be one of these
objects
cool so now that i remove this element
from the top of my stack
let's say for now i just i don't know
print it out maybe we'll kind of debug
this one as we go so i'll console.log
current.val because i know that every
instance of node has a val prop on the
inside
and then from there i need to add this
node's children so you might go ahead
and guess that to do that we can just do
stack.push i'm going to push
the
left child what's going on here so node
or current.left
followed by the right child
but we also need to make sure that these
children exist right if you look at the
prompt there could be instances for
example like this c node over here this
c node
only has a right child but has no left
child right so what i don't want to do
is push c's left because then i'll be
pushing null onto my stack which would
give me an error later on
right so i want to only push the
children if they exist and i need to
individually check if the left exists
and push it and also if the right exists
then push it so i'm just going to add
some guard statements for both of these
so we'll go ahead and we'll insert we'll
say all right
if the
current has a left and right so i'll say
current.left
and i'll adjust this for the right-hand
side
well maybe we can inline this
if you prefer
all right so i'm going to only push the
children if they exist
and that should actually be the heart of
our depth first algorithm so we're not
putting our values inside of an array
like the problem asks but we should at
least be able to see the correct order
of printing here because i'm going to
print a node's value as soon as it is
removed from my stack
so i'll go ahead and actually maybe
bring in
maybe one literal test case so i could
just steal
this little stub over here
and this will just print out the values
right so i'll test this i can hit run if
i hit run it's just going to execute
this file just like a script so it's not
going to run any automatic test cases
it's just going to run my file as is so
if you want to test it in this way kind
of in a manual way you're going to have
to be sure to call your function i do
have a console.log on the inside
so i'll just run this manually
and when i do that should see some
output here looks like node is not
defined because i forgot to bring in
my class definition
so i'll do that
give that a go
all right so looking at our output we
didn't get our exact depth first
traversal like we expected right i got
acf bed if you take a look at what we
really printed out we technically did
print out a depth first print
but we favored the right hand side so we
did a c f and then b e d
so let's say we really wanted the left
to right version of this now all you
have to do is flip the order that you
push the children right it should be
clear by looking at these two lines
right when i add my children looks like
i push the left child and then the right
child
if you push the left child first
and then you push the right child
afterwards that means that the right
child is going to be on top for the next
iteration
so if you do it like this this will
favor the right hand side and travel
through it first but if you did it like
this
now you'd be actually iterating to the
left branch first
toward the right
so with that small change
let's just see what our print is
and there we have a nice abd ecf
however in this problem they want us to
actually return those values in an array
so i can kind of get rid of this little
manual test over here i don't need this
class definition anymore
and now instead i'll just gather up all
of my values in some results array so
i'll say i don't know maybe a result
over here starts as an empty array and
then as i
pop elements from the top of my stack
instead of logging them i'll go ahead
and do
result.push and i'll push that value
into the result array
once i'm done with this while loop that
means my entire tree has been explored
in which case i can return
make sure you spell it right return my
result
cool so this should be a nice solution
let's actually run the test cases on
this
give that a go so it looks like we're
doing pretty good but for this very last
example looks like we're getting
uh can't read property val of null and
that's running test case zero four so if
you actually go into the prompt
those test cases are actually laid out
explicitly over here so i want to go to
zero four
yeah let's look at the zero four test
case ah they go ahead and they pass my
function
null right kind of representing like an
empty tree or an empty node and we can
kind of trace what happens here for our
code
let's say that
root was null
that means when we initialize our stack
our stack literally contains like a null
value so it's not even an instance of
nodes just null so that means when i
enter this while i'm going to check you
know do i have anything in my stack and
i do because my stack length is one and
then when i pop
the top element of my stack current is
going to be null then on this line 14 it
says null dot val and that's actually
where our code explodes right on line
14. right you can't reference property
val of null and so to handle this
scenario we want to make sure that we
actually never allow anything null to
enter the stack it's kind of why we had
this guard over here and that should
also be true for even the top level
route in case they give us the empty
tree kind of seems like a corny you know
edge case but this is a pretty common
one when you actually go into your
interviews right what happens when you
have an empty input
and so i'll just guard that explicitly
i'll go ahead and check hey if my root
so if my entire tree is empty so if root
equals null
then what i'll do is just return
an empty array right because that means
there are no values inside of it and
that actually is the expected answer
according to this right should return an
empty array so let's give it a go now
should be pretty good
nice and there we have our nice
iterative solution
for this depth-first values problem
all right so here's what we'll do that
was one solution let me show you another
way let's implement this and that would
be our recursive flavor so i'll just
kind of redefine it down below
and i actually recommend practicing both
versions
because they're going to serve as like
the basis for which you solve a lot of
different tree problems
and so when i think about the recursive
version now like all of our recursive
code i must think about the simplest
case of my input and that will act as my
base case right so in the case of a
binary tree the simplest tree you can be
given is going to be the empty tree or
just a null root right so it's not even
going to be about a node that's a single
node right inside of a binary tree it's
going to be about an empty tree right a
tree with zero nodes so i'm going to
check hey if
my root is null then i have an empty
tree and i think about this base case as
if it's its own input because it really
is right and so if someone asks me to
give them back an array of all the
values in the empty tree it's still the
case that this must be an empty array
right because there are no values
there's not even any nodes in the empty
tree
and then from there i can generate uh my
actual recursive call right
and i know when i call my stuff
recursively that means i have to
reference the function name again go
ahead and invoke it i'm going to call
upon root.left as well as root.right
all right so this would
this call over here would give me back
an array containing all of the values in
the left subtree and this would give me
an array of all of the values in the
right sub-tree
and so let's say i save these into their
own variables respectively you don't
have to do this part but
i'm kind of a fan of it especially if
it's the first time i'm implementing
this so i'll call this my left values
and i'll call this one my right values
and here is how i'm able to kind of
quickly
create recursive code it's all about
taking what i call is the recursive leap
of faith here
so let's say we're stepping through
test zero zero
so this is our our tree visual right
so we know that our root
is going to be the a node so when i
actually make this top level call this
base case does not fire and so i make my
recursive calls right i know when i do
depth first value or values rather let
me fix that
depth first values of root dot left that
means i'm going to be passing in the b
node right and here's how i have to
actually pretend my code behaves i'm
just going to get back the correct
result from this call right so if i
passed in the b node into this call what
i expect back is the full
array representing the depth first
reversal of that subtree starting at b
right so if i got correct data over here
what it would look like is just b
d and e
right that would actually be the full
depth first traversal from this subtree
right and i'm kind of doing that just
mentally i know the expectation for this
algorithm
it's going to be a similar story for my
right call right if i'm at a so a is
still my root and i passed in my right
child c
to this call what i expect back is just
an array of cf which would be the depth
first reversal of that left subtree
and now that i have you know my left
subtree values and my right subtree
values i have to think about how to
combine it all together right how do i
work myself into that output by
combining both of the results from my
children right what i need to do is
really just take myself put it in the
array followed by my left children
followed by my right children so i can
use some nice javascript syntax for that
i'm going to return a new array i'm
going to throw myself in there so i'm
going to throw in root.val that's myself
so that'd be like the a node then i just
take all the values in my left
result and put them in here i'm just
going to use the spread operator to
unpack that array and i'll do the same
thing for the right values of cf right
so dot dot dot
spread out right values just so i return
a single array and this pattern itself
does match this output right kind of
taking the leap of faith and assuming
correctness from these recursive calls
over here all right i have a
then i plug in substitute bde and then
for the right i have cf
maybe before we run this
i'm not going to you know assume too
much javascript knowledge so maybe
you're
kind of new to this spread operator so
in general super quick aside over here
let's say i had an array of some stuff
so i'll say
peeps
throw in some people over here
so we'll throw in felipe
we'll throw in
jason
throw in raj
throw in abby
and what i can do is whenever i have an
array i can just use a spread operator
to kind of unpack that array so for
example i can say const
we'll say new
peeps
and i'll create a new literal array so
whenever i say square brackets it gives
me a new array literal and what i'll do
is i don't know put an element at the
front we'll call it alvin
and i'll spread out the elements of
peeps right so just imagine i took all
the elements here and just removed the
brackets that way i don't add any
initial nesting
and then at the end i don't know i can
add
someone else
like ryan
well console.log what new peeps
looks like so i'm not going to run the
test cases we're just going to run this
file as a script
just so we can review this spread syntax
so if i give that a go we kind of make
this bigger notice that i have correctly
spreaded things out right have alvin at
the front and i have all of the things
from peeps in the middle right followed
by brian at the end so you can do this
you can also use like the concat method
on arrays you're probably going to see
me use this spread syntax a lot because
i'm kind of a fan right
but with that in mind let's go ahead and
actually test this code
so we'll run all the test cases
nice and this is another working
solution for our depth depth-first
values
and it should be pretty natural that we
can solve this problem also recursively
so i know that the iterative solution
for this depth first reversal requires a
stack data structure and i know whenever
i write recursive code under the hood
your programming language is actually
going to track all those recursive calls
using the call stack right that call
stack behavior gives you the same type
of ordering which is really convenient
cool all right so before i send you off
on the next problem i want you to
actually practice
both solutions for this depth first
values code it's going to be very
necessary to actually master some later
concepts that are coming right up so do
spend some time on this practice makes
perfect right and i'll catch you in the
next one
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over this breath first values
problem so it's really just going to be
a little variation off of the depth
first one we just did of course but it's
really important that moving forward for
all of our tree algorithms and other
data structures that we have both
versions down pat
so in this problem we're going to take
in a binary tree once again very classic
binary tree structure this time i want
to return an array or a list of all the
values according to a breath first
traversal order so a breath first
traversal starts with the the root note
of a so that's nothing new and then from
there i could go to b so right now i
have my a node and also my b node and
here is where we diverge from a previous
problem in a breath first traversal
breath just refers to like the width of
something i travel across before i go
deeper
so in our breath first reversal i'm
going to move to c and not d for now
so i add my c node c value to my list
and then from here once i've finished
this entire level and there's nowhere to
go across the tree anymore now i can go
downward to the next level so now i have
d and then e
and then f
so the really important distinction here
is
the breadth first reversal starts with
abc whereas the depth first traversal
would have started a b d
that's a really really important
distinction
and so how can we go about implementing
the breath first version of this
well recall that the depth first used a
stack data structure well it is the case
that the breath first is now going to
use the q data structure really just the
partnering version of that structure
and so let's kind of step through that
in a more programmatic way so i'm going
to use and track my cue and just recall
that a cue has you know a sense of
direction to it i have the back of my
cube and the front of my queue things
enter the back of the queue and they
leave the front of the queue
right and so no one gets to skip the
line either so this gives me a nice fair
ordering think of a queue as just like
waiting in line at checkout at a grocery
store or something
so how do i begin my algorithm well i
need to start by initializing my queue
with the root node so i'm just going to
start with a on my queue
then from here now i can begin my main
algorithm so my main algorithm should
check on every iteration
is my queue empty right now it's not
because i have at least one element and
so i remove the front element of my
queue
and so we know that a would be removed
and we'll label it as our current a node
being explored when something leaves the
queue and is marked as our current we'll
say that now it's being visited so i
would add a to the running list of my
values
and then from here i need to look at a's
children
a has two children b and c i need to go
ahead and add them into my queue
and so let's say i added b into the q
first
followed by c
notice that c must enter behind b right
and now i finish this iteration at this
point i have the next iteration of my
algorithm i take the front element of my
q and it leaves right so b is now my
current i add b to my running list then
i look at b's children of d and e
i push d
followed by e behind it at this point i
have another iteration to do right and
it's so on and so forth from here
c leaves the front of my q i add it to
my list of values and i look at c's
children c only has one child so for
that child that exists i go ahead and
add them to the back of my queue and
it's really important that i add it to
the back
all right at this point i have my next
iteration at this point i continue my
queue is still not empty so i still have
some stuff to remove so d leaves the
front of my queue i add it to my list of
values since d has no children there's
nothing to add here next iteration
e leaves the front of my queue i added
to my list of values no children so i
don't need to add anything and finally f
leaves the front of my cube i just add
it to my list of values and again f has
no children so by now my queue is empty
which must mean that hey i must have
completed the algorithm right there are
no more nodes to explore i explored and
added every single node to my list of
values
all right and this uh output actually
looks correct right i get a b c d e f
just like we say but what about the
complexity of this algorithm so let's
take a closer look over here
well we know from the get that n is
going to be the number of nodes in this
binary tree so that'll be the term for
our size of input and we can say that
the time complexity is simply just o of
n roughly because we know when it comes
to visiting these nodes and you know
using our loop we're going to add every
node to the queue once which also means
that that node's going to leave the
queue also once so it's not like we're
double adding a nodes to the queue right
we're not going to double visit any of
these
in a similar way the space complexity is
going to be o of n at most
because you know we're just going to add
at most to all of the nodes into our
cube and in general it's probably going
to be less than o of n space in terms of
how much space we use in our cube an
important thing i'll just mention right
now that in regards to the time
complexity of this one here we're going
to say that the time complexity is o of
n and that's if we can assume that
adding something uh to the q runs in
constant time and removing something
from the q occurs in constant time so
depending on how you implement this if
you use actually a built-in and
efficient cue data structure you will
get this o of n time complexity for our
breath first
but if you use a less optimal like data
structure maybe not a perfect q then you
might have an actual worse complexity so
again this time complexity of o of n
assumes that we have a maximally
efficient queue that has o of 1 add and
remove operations
with that being said i feel pretty good
about coding this one up i'll catch you
in the walkthrough video and i'll show
you a few different ways not to
implement this one
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to walk through the javascript
solution for this breath first values
function so hopefully you just finished
the depth first version in which case
this one should be pretty much a
cakewalk but of course we'll still go
through the motions of it because it's
going to be useful to solve much harder
problems later on as you always hear me
say all right so to tackle this one
we'll start with our q data structure
right so nothing fancy in javascript
what i would do is just use an array and
just stick to using very specific
methods right so i'm going to create an
array i'll call it myq
i'm going to initialize that q with
the root on it by default
and what i'll also guard against up
front is imagine they gave us an empty
tree to begin with so in other words the
initial route is null in which case that
would be like this test04 and they just
want us to return an empty array so i'm
going to guard for that explicitly so
i'll check hey is my root null and if it
is just go ahead and return
an empty array
like that
nice
and then from here i need to start my
main loop for my algorithm so i iterate
while my q is not empty just like we
spoke about in the approach video right
so while q.length is
greater than zero then keep on going
now i begin a single iteration of this
algorithm by just removing the front of
my queue right so it's really up to you
which methods you use you just need to
make sure you remove from one end and
add to the opposite end so for me i'm
going to treat index 0 as if it's the
front of my array i'm going to treat the
last index as if it's the back of my
array all right so if i want to remove
the front i can say array.shift or for
me right now q dot shift that removes
the front but also returns to me that
element so i'll call that my current
node
nice and then from here i need to add
this node's children into my queue and
that would give me my main flow for this
breath first traversal right so i'm
going to go ahead and check hey if my
left child exists so if
let's say current
dot left
that is not
null
then what i should do is go ahead and
push that into my queue so i'll say
q dot push
my current dot left
and it's just going to be symmetric for
the right hand side of course
so if the right exists then push the
right
into the q
e
just like that
awesome and so that looks pretty good
and then from there i actually want to
store the nodes i visit
in an array for the final return just
like the problem asks so nothing too
fancy
i really want to insert some code over
here about
and so i'll create a result array i'll
call it values
start out empty whenever something
leaves the queue i'll just take that and
push it into my values so i say
values.push
and i'll push that current val into my
queue
and do note that um what you can't do is
just take like the q and treat it like
your final return value it must be a
totally separate thing right i use the
cue just for the sake of traveling
through
in a breath first order and the order
that you visit is actually derived from
the order in which things leave the
queue so that's why i'm doing it over
here right as soon as something leaves
the queue that's when i consider it
visited so i add it to my values list
nice and after my while loop's done
running i'll go ahead and return
my entire values array
so let's give this a test i'm going to
run all the test cases see what we get
have a few
test cases to pass
and there we have it here's a nice
iterative solution for our breadth first
reversal
just something i want to mention by the
way
let's look at the prompt
so looking at i don't know like the very
first example
in this kind of rendition of breath
first what they ask us to do is really
give us a breath first reversal that
moves from left to right so notice it
goes a b c in terms of the resulting
output and not a cb right those would
both be technically a correct start to a
breath first and then you can kind of
choose depending on what problem you're
solving whether you want to go left to
right or right to left
for me because i push the left followed
by the right that means the left's going
to leave the queue first right because
remember the queue is just like a line
in checkout so if someone enters first
that is the left enters first they're
going to be served before the right
you can just flip these around and i'll
give you the right to left traversal
cool so depending on what your problem
warrants you can always manipulate that
code a little bit
and this is actually probably like the
only solution you can have
you know
maybe aside from just some superficial
changes to like the code style this is
going to be your go-to and only go-to
solution for a breath first reversal on
a binary tree right a common mistake i
see people try to do a lot is there is
not really a straightforward way to
implement a breath first reversal
recursively and that should make some
sense because a breath first traversal
uh needs a queue order right needs to
use a cue if you write any recursive
code you know under the hood it's using
a stack and so that stack versus q is
really just gonna fight against you and
you're going to have a really tough time
trying to implement the correct ordering
so
always just write the iterative version
for your breath first reversal
all right so i recommend before you hop
into the next video make sure you're
able to write this code on your own
because we are going to level up
difficulty in a little bit but i'll
catch you in the next one
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to walk through the approach for
this tree includes problem
so premise of this problem is i'm going
to give you a binary tree and also a
target value to look for i just want you
to tell me true or false is that target
value found within the binary tree so
for this particular example input the
answer is obviously true or yes right
you could definitely find e within this
binary tree if i give you another target
value like j you would respond with
false right because that value j is
nowhere to be found within the binary
tree and really what i'm asking you to
do here is we're stepping through the
canonical like breath first search and
depth-first search problems and i think
i'll walk through both approaches for
you right now
so let's say i was testing or i wanted
to trace through rather the input where
target was e how can i go about
attacking this one right we know that in
most of these problems when they give
you a binary tree as input they're only
going to give you really the root node
but that being said if you have access
to the root node then you know you have
access to all nodes that comprise the
tree right so what i can do is just
perform any of my traversal algorithms
so maybe to get going now let's just do
uh either the breath first search or the
depth first search iterative uh style so
i think for this trace i'll stick to the
breath first version which means we're
going to use a cue right so as we trace
through this i'm thinking about this one
iteratively right now
hopefully you recall from our previous
problems when it comes to your breath
first traversal
you start with your root node on your q
and when something leaves the queue
you mark it as your current right and
here's where i work in the new logic for
this this particular problem
when something leaves the front of my
queue i'm going to check hey is that
current value the same as my target
value so is a the same as e it's not so
i have not found the thing i'm looking
for right and what i can do is now
consider a's children
all right so i look at ace children they
both exist i add them to the queue so i
add b to my q then i add c to my q and
now i'm on to my next iteration right
the front element b leaves the q then i
have to check hey is b my target it's
not right my target's e so i keep
running i look at b's children so i take
that d and add it in and i take the e
and also add it
and this process just continues c leaves
in front of my q
is c my target
it's not so keep going
i would add c's children to my q so i
just add f to my q
and this process continues and so d
leaves the front of my q i check is d my
target it's not and d has no children to
add right recall that in our breath
first traversal i only add the children
if they exist because i don't want to
add any like null pointers into my queue
and so i just continue my algorithm
right i still have stuff on my q to
check and finally when e leaves the
front of my queue i check
is e my target and indeed it is right at
this point i've just confirmed that e is
found inside of my binary tree so what i
can do is just end my algorithm by like
returning the true value right there's
no points of actually looking through
the rest of the tree because i already
figured out that hey my target value is
indeed within the tree all right one
thing you might notice is
it looks like i only checked
for e once it left the front of my queue
and not when it was initially added to
my queue technically you could have
returned early when you added it to the
queue but we'll kind of see when i walk
through the full code for this one it
would end up with cleaner code if you
just checked
for your target value when something
leaves your queue
so we'll see that when we go through the
code it's just a small implementation
detail that being said for this
iterative breadth first strategy what
can we say about the complexity well if
we define n
as the number of nodes then we know that
the time complexity is just o of n it's
really just a classic breath first
traversal so nodes are going to enter
the queue once and leave the q1 so
that's of n right and again that's
considering if we use a efficient queue
right where our q add and remove
operations run an o of one constant time
so we have linear time and for the space
complexity it's also going to be o of n
linear right because we're just going to
store
our nodes within the q
and so we just looked at the approach
for a nice iterative breadth first
solution not to this problem but i want
to show you
the depth first version and the depth
first version that would be recursive
right so obviously you could write the
iterative depth first solution which
case you just use basically the same
code we just spoke about but just use a
stack instead of the q
but let's try to solve this one
recursively right and the reason i think
it's really important to expose yourself
to recursion like this is as we move to
more complex topics uh you're going to
find this style of recursion very very
useful right
so we have the same input right let's
say my target is e and i have the same
binary tree and i want to check
recursively is e within this tree
and so how do we start attacking this
well we're going to need to think about
our base cases right
so we're going to have really two types
of base cases we'll have like the
affirmative base case meaning hey we
found a match and so whenever i counter
a node whose value is e or whose value
matches my target then i'm going to have
that node or that recursive call return
true right so that's my like affirmative
base case so i'm just going to plug that
return value individually in my tree you
know that this e node's going to return
true
and now i'll think about my negatory
base case right
for
times where i call upon an empty node or
the null node
i should return false and recall from
our previous lectures we said that we're
going to you know sometimes represent
explicitly our null nodes so i'm going
to fill those in for example the c node
in my picture would have a left child
that is null so i'll kind of draw that
one explicitly and i know that a node
like that is going to return false
because logically i should be able to
think about all of my recursive calls as
if they're their own subproblems right
so if someone asked me hey can you find
this e value within an empty tree right
a null node represents an empty tree the
answer would be no i can't find the e
value in an empty tree because there's
nothing there
and so from there i'm also going to draw
explicitly
all of those similar null nodes null
pointers right so it looks something
like this
notice that from the e node i don't need
to give it a null left and right because
i already said that that node's going to
return true right so that's why i draw
my tree like this
and i have all of those false return
values
cool so we just labeled all of the base
cases right as the leaves of our tree
and recall that a leaf is just a node
with with no uh children right
and from here how do i actually combine
all of these boolean values to get the
true at the very top because i know for
my top level caller that is at the a
node or the a recursive call i need to
get back that value of true
right
and the logic we should use is really
just the logical or
so how does this one work so let's start
evaluating
our return values and combining them at
the parent so this should be somewhat of
a similar pattern to like the tree sum
problem i showed you and so what we
could do is focus on this d note over
here this node
has values ready on its left and right
it has two falses
and when it actually gets those falses
returned to it it just should do the
logical or so it's doing false or false
which evaluates to false right which
means that hey in this subtree rooted in
d i cannot find the e value which makes
sense that's why it's false
i'll continue this process if i look at
this b node now this b node has values
ready on its left and right and they're
going to bubble up a little bit
and i take the or of them so i do false
or true which evaluates to true
and this process continues everywhere in
the tree right so at this f node false
or false gives me false
at the c node false or false gives me
false
finally at the top level root of a
i do
true or false giving me back a final
true which is indeed the correct answer
so hopefully you realize how similar
this solution is to our previous tree
sum problem right in the tree sum
problem i combined
my left and right
child return values by doing the
arithmetic addition but this time around
i just need to use the boolean operation
of or right so by just adjusting the
type of the tabooline we have a very
very elegant solution shout out george
boole
and so with that i think let's go ahead
and implement this one in some code and
i'll show you it uh using the iterative
flavor using maybe a breath first and
also
the recursive version which is my
personal favorite uh using this
recursive tree structure
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this tree includes problem right and
we'll solve this both depth first and
also breath first and i think we'll
start with the iterative breath first
version and so this is really just going
to be implementation of the classic
breath first search algorithm so i'm
just going to lay down my classic breath
first traversal code and then just add
some conditional logic afterwards right
so you should be familiar with it by now
but for my breath first uh traversal i'm
gonna use a cube so i'll say const q
equals an empty array or really an array
with the root thrown on the inside
and from there i have my main algorithm
right so i loop while my q is not empty
so while q length is bigger than zero
and keep on going
and on a single iteration of this
traversal what i do is q dot shift so
remove from the front of my queue or the
front of my array
remove the
first element
and i'll save that into a variable
called current so that will be just an
instance of node and for now oh why
don't i just build up my solution slowly
i'll just i don't know
console.log what current.val is
but once i consider this node what i
want to do is really add its children
into my queue only if they exist though
right so in general i'm going to write
like q dot push so i'm going to add to
the back of my q so i get a nice q order
push the left child so current left
likewise the right child
but imagine that i have an asymmetric
node or just a leaf node right something
like c would only have a right child so
it's left would be null so if current is
c
then i'd be pushing null
into my queue as the left which is no
good right and so i need to guard here
and only push the children if they exist
so something like this hey if
the current has that corresponding left
and right then i can go ahead
and push it
so this is looking pretty good
and that should actually be
the main traversal part of the code so
i'll just test this manually
so very manually so
maybe just this call so i'm not going to
return booleans yet
we'll build up to that but i should at
least see my values printed if i kind of
run this manual test case i'll bring in
my node class i should see the values
printed in a correct breath first order
so that means a b c
d e f recall that breath first traversal
travels across our tree
before going lower so it must finish a
level before traveling to the next level
so let's just run this manually as a
script
see what we get here
a b c d e f nice so i'm getting the
right order of traversal
and now i can work in i think
the conditional logic because they want
us to return booleans
over here
so pretty straightforward stuff i'll go
ahead and check once something leaves
the queue i can check
if the current node's value is equal to
my target then i've found the thing i'm
looking for so just return true right
you're done you don't need to travel
through the rest of the tree because you
can return true
but on the flip side if my
value that i'm currently at is not the
target value then i must continue
looking through the rest of the tree
right
so if i finish the entire while loop
that means i've traveled through the
entire tree and i never found the thing
i'm looking for i should return false so
i need a late return false over here
a really common mistake people tend to
make is
what you don't want to do is just do
like else return false here
so this is going to be wrong
right because this would only check like
the very first note it's only check the
root and then you check if the root is
not
equal to the value if it's not you just
return false which is not really useful
because it could be somewhere else in
the tree so you're going to need that
late return false pattern over here
but with that i think we're going to
pass some of the test cases
so i'll run the test cases by hitting
that test button and there's probably
one scenario we did not foresee
cool and there it is right cannot read
property val of null we're failing test
zero five if i look at that spec
test five gives us the null node as our
root right so just the empty tree you
cannot find the b
character inside of the empty tree so
return it looks like false over here and
so i can just handle that one explicitly
i'll go ahead and check at the top
if my root is null
right if that's the case then just
return false so i can't possibly find
any target in an empty tree
right
the reason our code was failing before
is if root is null then i initialize my
q with null and when that
thing is popping that null is popped or
rather shifted from the queue on the
first iteration then i check null.val
which is an illegal
javascript operation
so i'll run all these test cases now
nice and there we have our breath first
solution for this tree includes problem
all right now let's work on the
recursive depth first version of this
it's actually my personal favorite
because it utilizes a pattern that i
think is quite elegant and one i use a
lot for much more difficult problems
so like we said in the approach video if
you haven't watched the approach ready
you definitely want to check it out for
this recursive version right
what i should do is check hey if my
route is null if i have the empty tree
basically then just return false right
because i can't possibly find my target
in an empty tree right that's just a
given
and from there i know i'm going to have
the general shape of some just depth
first traversal code which means you
call the same function because it's
recursive that's what recursive means
and you pass along your root dot left
and a separate call your root right and
what i should be sure to do is don't
forget to pass in your target right the
target that you're looking for never
changes
and i know that these two
these two calls are going to give me
back boolean data and i know that the
boolean i get back from like this call
would represent whether or not i found
the target in that subtree right so this
gives me the result of if i found it in
the left subtree or the result if i
found it in the right subtree and i can
just do the logical or on both of these
right
so if i find it in either subtree then
return true so i can just write an
inline return true over here right so
let's say it's in my right subtree then
this left hand side evaluates to false
and this is true in which case this
entire thing evaluates to true and let's
say in a bad scenario let's say it's not
found in either subtree so this
evaluates to false this right hand side
also evaluates to false false or false
gives me false
however one thing i need to be sure to
add is also an additional base case
after i check if my root is null now
what i want to do is then
also check hey maybe this root i'm
currently at maybe it actually has the
target right so if root valve is equal
to the target then you're also done
except you can return true
cool and that was very reminiscent of
our approach video
so let's give this a shot
we should be able to pass nice and i
love how
clean this code is i will admit you know
it's pretty tricky if you're not a fan
of writing recursion in which case i'll
totally convince you into being a fan of
recursion
but notice how kind of clean this code
is it really leverages a recursion
uh one very important thing i want to
bring up is it's really
keen that i put this
base case on line 26 after the null
check right so let's say i flip the
order of these let's say you did this
i believe that would not work out always
because it assumes that you even have a
root right so i'm feeling a test zero
zero but in general if you look at this
code let's say that root was null right
you're going to start by checking null
dot val and that will throw an error
right cannot read property vowel of null
so you want to actually always lead with
your base case that checks if your root
is null right because that should guard
really the entirety of our code so this
is actually the code you want over here
all right programmers so that's all i
got for this tree includes a solution i
want you to practice both versions and
i'll catch you in the next one
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over the approach for this
tree sum problem
and so in this problem i want to take in
a binary tree just like we've been doing
as of late this time the values within
the nodes of this binary tree are going
to be numbers right what i want you to
do is compute the total sum of all the
values in this tree so for this example
we should end up with 25
and so hopefully you're kind of
gathering how to attack this problem
especially given you know the algorithms
i've been showing you as of late so if
you've been studying our problems in
order hopefully you know a
straightforward solution to solve this
one we could of course just use any type
of traversal algorithm so we can use
either a breadth first or a depth first
traversal and we can just add all these
values into a running sum and of course
we'd probably initialize that sum to
zero right so the iterative breadth
first or depth first solution i think is
very straightforward right and i'm not
going to really step through that
approach with you over here i think you
have that one down pat especially if
you've done the previous two problems
but what i will show you here is
actually how to solve this one
recursively which would be a type of
depth first
traversal because we know that hey depth
first traversal relies on a stack and if
you do something recursive it is
utilizing the underlying
call stack so i will get a similar type
of ordering
and so when we trace through uh this
type of solution this recursive solution
for this tree sum problem what we're
gonna do is try to be very explicit and
i think this is really helpful
especially if you struggle uh with
recursion right so given this binary
tree i know that for particular nodes of
my tree like the four node it does not
have a left child
right and i know like programmatically
what that means is like that node's dot
left pointer points to like null right
it's a null pointer
and so i'm just going to draw that
explicitly sort of like this
again that will just help us
really understand how our recursive code
performs on this type of input
and so if i know that i can put like a
null node to the left of four
then it could be the case that
other nodes like the leaves of two and
one they also have both a left and right
children that are also null so if i drew
all of my null pointers explicitly it
would look something like this
cool
and this is a really something that
helped me really get comfortable with
recursive problems especially those on
binary
trees and what we're doing now is we
know that when it comes to solving any
problem recursively it's about writing a
base case that is like the simplest
version of our input
and here i'm going to argue that our
base case needs to be about the null
node right the null node basically
represents
no node at all or represents the empty
tree in a sense
in other words if someone asked me to
calculate the sum
of a null node or the sum of an empty
tree then to me that sum would just be
zero to write elegant recursive code try
to think about your base case as a
problem in itself right so if someone
gave me an empty tree that is a null
node i would return the total sum of
zero and what that means is i know that
all of these null nodes they would
return 0
as their computed sums
nice and then from there how can i use
this information to actually build up my
main solution
right so let's go ahead and target this
four node to the left
and what i have to do is figure out hey
what is this subtree's total sum
and i can compute that given the values
to the left and right in other words if
i return those two null values returns
so they're both zero
now i just have to do zero plus four
plus zero which just equates to four
right and that is actually correct in
itself right so a green number above a
node represents the total sum of that
subtree and so it is the case that hey
the total sum of that four node is just
four
and i would do something similar for
this node over here right
when these base cases return to their
caller or return to their parent
i just have to add my left and right
child together along with myself so 0
plus 2 plus 0
gives me 2. and i'll do that same thing
for this note 11 over here and now
things get interesting right to
calculate the total sum
rooted at this 11 subtree i would just
return these values to the top and now i
do 4 plus 11 plus 2 which gives me an
answer of 17. and if you do a quick spot
check right
this 17 does represent uh the total sum
just in this subtree right
and we'll carry on
over at this one node we know that this
is going to return just a value of one
and now at this four node i can compute
its total sum and recall that this four
node had a left child of zero right
because it had a null node
and so when i compute this sum i get
five which is perfect and finally at the
main root
now i bring up these two values and i
compute 17 plus 3 plus 5 and that gives
me a final answer of 25 which is indeed
the correct answer right so that's how
we should really think about our
recursive algorithms for our binary
trees right i kind of draw it out i
think about the base case which is
typically not always but typically about
the null node and then from there i
figure out how a parent can compute its
result given its children's answers
all right so if we take a look at the
complexity of this it's pretty
straightforward we'll go ahead and
define n as the number of nodes in our
input tree in which case i can see that
my time complexity is just o of n right
we know that we're going to make a
recursive call just for every node of
the tree and we're not going to call
duplicate nodes right we're going to
have just one call for every single node
and within any single node we're just
going to do some simple arithmetic right
we just add roughly three numbers
together so it's not like we're going to
have like a loop inside of our calls at
all
in a similar way we'll say the space
complexity is o of n
just because we have that implicit a
call stack space because we are going to
solve this one recursively
and so we're solving this one in o of n
time and space which would be actually a
maximum efficient a solution for this
problem
and so with that i think let's head over
to the walkthrough video and i'll show
you how to code this one up
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to walk through the javascript
solution for this tree sum problem and i
think this time around i'll jump right
into the recursive version right
so we'll start recursively and we'll
begin with our base case right my base
case is always about the simplest
version of the input where i just know
the answer without needing any
additional calculations right i know
that the simplest tree here that i could
be given is going to be the empty tree
right if i have the empty tree that
means my root is null
and if your root is null and you have
the empty tree what is the sum of the
empty tree well kind of inherently it's
just zero so that'll be my base case
nice then from there i'll think about
how i can compute
my answer given my children results so i
need to find the result of the sum of my
left subtree and also the sum of my
right subtree so just call recursively
so tree sum of root left
as well as
tree sum of root right
cool
and i know that these two calls they
return
numbers right representing the sum of my
left subtree and the sum of my right
subtree
as the parent that is as the root how
can i find my total sum well it just is
myself so root dot value plus everything
in my left subtree
plus everything in my right subtree
right
and we'll go ahead and just test this
out the gate
but this is nothing fancy a really
elegant code so look at the test cases
here we do have some a diverse output so
this code does work on trees of all
different shapes and sizes
uh something that helps me you know
really believe the magic of recursion is
to just analyze the assumptions here
right so let's say that i'm stepping
through tree sum and my root is this 3
over here right so i check the base case
is this 3 node no it's not so i must
make the recursive call right and i know
that when i break down this code
recursively i know what root that val is
going to be like three so i'm kind of
corresponding uh this comment with the
thing below right
and then when i make the recursive call
on tree sum root dot left that means i'm
asking for the total sum
of this subtree starting at 11. so i'm
looking at the 11 4 negative 2
subtree right if i take the total sum of
just that left subtree it looks like
it's going to be
13.
so now i'm saying plus 13 over here
right if i do the same thing on the
right subtree i know that this call
is for this four node right all of its
children
that should just magically return by the
power of recursion that should return
five right i'm going to assume that that
recursive call just works
so you have the five right if i take the
total sum of these
3 plus 13 16 16 plus 5 is 21 that would
give me the correct answer right so to
have some confidence in my recursive
code i just write the code and then i
assume correctness from my recursive
calls and i figure out how i can take
those no sub values from my children
combine it with my own value and that
should be my final answer
so here is the recursive version of this
solution which would be some sort of a
depth first traversal technically
because it's recursive
and if you'd like i can also show you
the iterative version so let's just do
that
and i always practice usually my
problems doing both the recursive as
well as iterative version if it's
reasonable and it is really reasonable
here hopefully you're familiar with our
breadth first code by now right so i'm
just going to start by checking
hey if you're given some root that is
already null then that's kind of just an
edge case i'll just go ahead and return
zero right because the sum of that empty
subtree or that empty tree rather is
just zero then i can begin my main code
so while my q
is not empty so i'll start with a q
who begins with the root
root
and i want to loop while my q is not
empty so while q dot length is bigger
than zero
i'll begin a single iteration of my
while loop by just shifting out the
front of my queue so in javascript for
me that's q dot shift that removes the
front element and also returns it to me
so i'll save it in current
and then from there now that i have this
current i know that that contains the
value that i actually care about so what
i would do is go ahead and track some
running sum so i'll say let's sum or
maybe say let total sum equals zero
and as i remove something from the front
of the queue i'll take its value and add
it to my total sum
so that will accumulate all of the
values right into a sum
then from there i just need to add my
classic logic of checking for my
children right if they exist so if i
have a left so if current.left is not
equal to null
then what i'll do is add that left child
into my queue so q dot push
my
current dot left
again make sure you're following your q
rules right so shift removes from the
front
push adds to the back it's really
important that my shift and my push or
my add and remove methods work on
opposite sides of my queue otherwise
it's not a cue right so that looks good
to go and i'll write something symmetric
for the right hand side over here
and by the end of my function i'll just
go ahead and return
my total sum
nice so this would be my go to uh
iterative version
of course it's technically a breath
first and we'll give that a test
nice and here we have
that solution
so one thing to note i think it's pretty
important to be consistent in how you
implement these algorithms at least
where possible so you'll notice that i
always am a fan of
writing my like processing logic for a
node here i consider like the processing
logic
where i add the value of my current node
into my total sum i do that processing
logic typically when a node leaves the
queue
and not when the node is added to the
queue and just ends up being less
repetitive that way for example i've
seen some people write code like this
where it's like all right well you know
i guess since i'm adding my left child
into
my
queue that means it exists so not only
will i push it but i'll add it so i'll
do i don't know total
sum plus equals current dot left dot
val right so i'm kind of
adding the
child's value as soon as it's added to
the queue
and you can write something symmetric
for the right hand side
you can see that because of this i kind
of have to double up all of my code
which
does not make it super clean
and i think something that
is even worse than that is
well now you actually never added your
root value
into your your total sum so you would
have to begin your total sum as root.val
and at this point i'm like i kind of
just hate this code right so you can run
this this would probably work
so this code totally works but it's not
uh what i think is the best design for
this pattern so i'd rather write it like
this right
consume your values when they leave
your q because you know eventually
everything's going to leave right
so i'll prefer it at least like
this
cool so before you go on to the next
problem recommend you practice both
versions i know of this problem so do
recursively do it iteratively have them
both down pat because we're going to
increase the difficulty right now
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over the approach for this
tree min value problem
so just like we've been doing as of late
we're going to have to take in a binary
tree as input into our function
what we want to do is figure out what
the smallest value within the tree is
that is we want to find the minimum
value so we can totally assume that the
tree is going to be uh non-empty right
and so given that information looking at
this particular tree example it's pretty
plain for us to see that the smallest
number in the tree is just this three
right so our function just needs to
return the number three and so it's
plain to see that the answer is three
but how can we come up with an algorithm
to do this for us well we should look to
our tools in our binary tree toolbox and
that would mainly just be either a
breath first or a depth first traversal
one obvious way to solve this one is to
use either a depth first or
breadth-first iterative piece of code
that does a traversal and travels
through the tree then you just need to
maintain some outer variable to track
the current minimum and whenever you hit
a node that is smaller than your current
minimum then you replace that minimum
variable and by the end of the code you
should have the true minimum
so the iterative version i think is
pretty straightforward and i'll be sure
to walk through that when we get to the
code walkthrough but for now in terms of
our approach visual i think we'll step
through this one recursively right
because it ends up being a pretty
succinct code
and so let's take a look at this tree
and let's pretend that we filled in all
of the null pointers like usual right so
these dark nodes over here represent
nodes that don't exist meaning that
they're
null right so for example if i look at
the three node its left child is null
but it's right child is 12.
and that's going to be very useful for
us to at least visualize because i
should make a base case about those null
nodes right so i know in the long run
what i want to do is figure out what the
smallest value within the tree is
and so a great default value for our
null nodes would be to return infinity
and here's the reasoning why i know that
i should not really consider any of the
actual null nodes and so if i have them
return positive infinity i know that
positive infinity is definitely not
going to be the minimum compared to any
numbers that are actually within the
tree
so what we'll start to do is just fill
in all of these infinite values in other
words every time we call upon a null
node or a null pointer we're going to
return infinity so i'd fill all of these
in
now using those infinities as our basis
we can actually construct our return
values so looking at this four node to
the left what i have to do is consider
both of its children that it receive
right and also the value within the
current node and so what i do is i check
all right compared between infinity 4
and infinity what's the smallest value
among them well i know positive infinity
is a very large number so really the
smallest number here should be 4.
and so this call should return 4 right
this node should return 4.
similar story for this 15 node once i
have my left and right return values
ready i do a comparison with those
values against myself right so i check
what's the minimum among infinity 15 and
infinity the minimum is 15. and things
get interesting now that we're at
evaluating this 11 node right now i have
some actual numbers and so i do this
comparison right
i compare my left subtree value which is
4 and my right subtree value which is 15
and also myself which is 11. so among 4
11 and 15 what's the smallest number
well that would just be the 4 right so
this node should return 4.
and if i do a quick spot check this
makes some sense because i have this
answer of 4 above the 11 node so that's
telling me that within that subtree
rooted at 11 the smallest value is 4
which is totally correct now we'll just
go ahead and evaluate the rest of this
tree looking at this 12 over here i know
i can't evaluate the 3 because i need a
value on the right hand side ready so i
must evaluate this 12 and i just do the
comparison right what's the minimum
among infinity 12 and infinity well
that's just definitely 12. finally at
this 3 node i take the minimum of
infinity 3 and 12. the minimum there is
3
and finally at the ultimate root i do
the comparison and i check what's the
smallest among 4 5 and 3 and the answer
is going to be
the 3 right which is exactly what we
expected and so just by adding a little
variation to our classic depth-first
recursion we can totally solve this
problem the logic we need to use to
combine our child sub solutions into our
main solution is to just do a comparison
right so overall at every point of this
tree we asked ourselves right given the
smallest value in the left sub tree and
given the smallest value in the right
subtree i compare those to myself and
return the smallest among those three
and now when it comes to the complexity
of this it's pretty straightforward
we'll go ahead and say that n is the
number of nodes within our input tree
and we know that we're going to have a
call for every note of this tree so that
seems to be o of n time in terms of the
number of recursive calls right and we
know within any particular recursive
call it sounds like we're just going to
do some conditional logic right just
find the minimum among three things
since three is a constant number i'm
pretty sure that we're going to have
just an overall time complexity of o of
n considering the number of calls that
we make now that being said we will also
have o of n space complexity just due to
the call stack that we use for our
baseline depth first traversal
and this seems to be an optimal solution
for this problem here's what we'll do
we'll go ahead and code this one up and
i'll catch the next one
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this tree min value problem
and of course we'll solve this one a few
different ways
i think i'll start by showing y'all
maybe some iterative solutions and so
we'll just do some classic depth first
and also breath first along the way
right so you know you're going to need
to iterate or hit every node within your
binary tree so just go ahead and set up
either a stack or a queue so i'll choose
to start with a stack over here so i'll
say const stack equals empty
and one thing i'll have to be aware of
is looking at
the assumptions in the problem they tell
us that we can assume that the input
tree is not empty and so that means i
won't need to add a leading if statement
checking if the top level root is null
so i can just go ahead and initialize my
stack
with the root node inside
cool then from there you need your main
loop to iterate through the different
nodes so i'm going to loop while my
stack is not empty so i'll stack
stack.length
is bigger than zero
cool so if that's the case and there are
still some nodes to visit i begin a
single iteration of this algorithm let's
say depth first by doing stack.pop so i
remove the top of my stack go ahead and
call that my current
and then from there of course we need to
check
if our children exist
and if they do i'll add them to the top
of my stack right so i'll write a
pattern like this i'll say if
let's say current dot
left that is not equal
to null then i can go ahead and push
that existing child on the stack right
so stack dot
push
and i'll push current.left
written this a few times by now should
be second nature i'll do some same code
for the right hand side and this is kind
of my baseline of a depth first
traversal right but as i look at this
current node and its value i want to by
the end of my loop have access to the
minimum value within the tree and so
because i need to find the minimum value
in this function i'm going to use a
variable that i'll update over time
right to track the current smallest
thing i've seen so i'll initialize this
as let's smallest i'm going to think
about a good default value for this
and so i'll go ahead and initialize this
to actually positive infinity so if
you're unfamiliar with some javascript
infinity is basically just a number that
is guaranteed to be bigger than all
other numbers except for itself infinity
right and the reason i'm choosing a big
number like positive infinity for my
default value for the smallest variable
is because when i see any actual values
of my tree i know they're guaranteed to
be
less than infinity so these numbers
would replace my infinity just gives me
a good initial value right that's a
pretty common pattern right if you're
looking for the minimum thing then
typically your default value is positive
infinity if you're looking for a maximal
thing then your default value might be
zero or negative infinity depending on
the problem you're trying to solve
and so with that default value where do
i actually want to replace it right and
i'll choose to do that right after
something leaves my stack that way i
only have to say it once if i wrote it
when i added my children into the stack
i'd have to say it twice right which is
kind of annoying so i'll just check okay
if current value so be sure to compare
the actual number value
current value is less than the smallest
then i've just found a new smallest
right so just replace that variable
with current val
of course by the end of our while loop
we should just return that variable
right and we should have the true
minimum
so let's give that a shot run these test
cases
and this is our rendition of an
iterative depth first right
awesome so if you wanted to switch it up
you know writing the breath first is
super
trivial in terms of the change we make
you can just make sure you do stack dot
shift
right because that would remove the
front element
of your cue now and if you push then
you're still adding it to the back and i
guess you should probably rename this
guy to
q
so very minute difference
well test that
give that a go
cool passes all of them
nice
and one thing to note
so at least in javascript there is no
immediate at least when i recorded this
video there is no immediately available
like optimal queue data structure just
baked in like you can't import it
through a standard library and so when
you actually do the array.shift method
that line itself is going to run in o of
n time right because if you remove the
front element of an array in javascript
it will have to actually shift all the
other elements
over one position in other words
index one becomes index zero index two
becomes index one and so on and so
technically uh if you implemented your
breadth first exactly like this just
using a regular array and you shift out
then this would probably be technically
like an o n squared solution which isn't
the fastest but we'll be able to pass
the specs typically you know n squared
for most problems is kind of okay but
you can avoid it if you want to get the
blazing fast solution
but now let's actually go ahead and
implement my favorite version which
would be
a recursive version right which is
technically of the depth first
right so we'll say const
is it treatment
value yeah treatment value
dream and value
and to establish this one recursively
we'll always start with our base case
right so we need some of these
curly guys
so i'll start with my base case i'll say
if my route
is equal to null then that kind of means
i have the empty tree so what's like the
minimum value in the empty tree well
that must be
infinity right for the same reason we
chose infinity before right it's just a
good default value because i'm going to
minimize in the long run
cool
and now what i want to do is i want to
make my recursive call so
if i call treemin value
on my left child
and i call it on my right child
i'll just think about what these
function calls return right although
they're recursive
if these calls work they should give me
back the smallest value in the left
subtree and the smallest value in the
right subtree so
maybe just to be clear i'll go ahead and
save these to some variables so i'll say
const i'll say
left
min
and also this should be the rightman
right
so i found the smallest and the left and
the smallest in the right but i also
need to think about myself right i am
root.val
so i need to choose the smallest of
root val leftmin and rightman right so
you can write like a conditional so
there's some if statements if you want i
think the best way to implement this in
javascript is just to use the math.min
function
so in javascript you always have access
to the global capital math object has a
few useful methods on it one we're going
to find useful right now is math.min
and if you do that you can pass in some
arguments and an arbitrary number of
arguments so give me the smallest
between root.val be sure to access the
value because you need to give numbers
to min right
smalls between root.val
leftman and my rightman
cool and this feels somewhat similar to
the approach drawing we did right where
we had to choose the smallest of these
three numbers so before we run it maybe
you're unfamiliar with math.min i can
quickly demo that for you let's say i
had some numbers we had 10 we had 3 we
had
6 and we had
negative
12 and also
100
and if i console log with that returns
i'll just run this file as a script so
i'm not going to execute the test quite
yet
so i should get negative 12 because
that's the smallest perfect and now i
think we're ready to go ahead and test
this
so our recursive version there we have
it
cool all right so there we have our
javascript walkthrough for this treemin
value problem i recommend you practice
all of these different solutions and
then pick a favorite maybe just have it
in your back pocket that way you can
always solve this problem in the future
right so you should have no issue
thinking about how to solve like a tree
max value problem and by now you know
we're getting pretty comfortable with
trees
and typically we're always going to fall
back to either a breath first or a depth
first reversal but in the next few
problems we're definitely going to look
at some spin-offs and some variations on
how we can accomplish more complex logic
using these algorithms as our baseline
so i'll catch you in the next one
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over this max root to leaf
path sum problem pretty wordy title
let's take a look at what this problem
asks us to do
so we're going to be taking in a binary
tree as input and we want to do is
really talk about the paths within this
tree in particular root to leave paths
so just to review we know that a binary
tree typically for us has a single root
and you can identify the root by just
looking at the topmost node that is the
node with no parent right and then also
given this tree there are three leaves
right
a leaf is a node that has no children so
do bear in mind right a root has no
parent a leaf node has no children
something like 11 and 3 in this picture
they're neither roots nor leaves right
so it could be the case that a tree has
many leaves like this tree right has
three leaves
but a tree for us typically only has a
single root
and so what we want to do is consider
all three of the different root to leave
paths right so you must start at the
root and you must terminate at a leaf so
one of those paths would just be this
one right 5 11 4. and what we want to do
is consider its total sum so just
summing the values within the nodes
along that path if i do 5 plus 11 plus 4
that would give me a total sum of 20. so
that's just one of the possibilities if
i look at another path let's say this
path of five eleven two five plus eleven
plus two would give me eighteen that's
another option and the only other option
is this final path from five to one if i
do five plus three plus one that gives
me a total sum of nine right and now
among those three options i want to
choose the maximal path sum right so
that would be a final answer of 20. so
in the long run we need to come up with
some code that computes the maximal path
sum
from the root to any leaf
and that sounds like a pretty hard
problem right how can we go about doing
that one
well hopefully you notice some similar
patterns right it's a problems we've
done previously so just by looking at
the name of this problem i'm reminded of
a few different patterns right i can
think of the tree sum problem seems
pretty related here and can i also think
about like that min value problem or we
had some minimization logic except now i
want to maximize something here
and so probably what i'll have to do in
this one is combine some of my previous
knowledge to come up with a pretty novel
solution but it's okay to rely heavily
on our previous experiences right
and so let's start with something
classic i think we're going to solve
this one recursively and in the grand
scheme of things typically you know for
tree problems that is a recursive code
is usually your best bet when it comes
to like path finding things right
building pads and determining paths
and so we'll take a look at what we
should have our base cases be if we're
going to frame this one recursively so
they tell us that all right you need to
consider paths but not just any paths
right you always want to end at a leaf
node so the leaf node's like the ending
point the leaf node is the base case
so my basis is going to be literally
about a leaf node and recall that that's
a node with no children so for example
let's say we had a node as input that
had no children
then what's the total sum
of that leaf node well it would just be
its inner value n right so kind of think
about your base cases as if they're
their own inputs right
as a quick aside right so a totally
separate scenario right now let's say i
gave you a tree that contains only one
node and its value was 42 and i asked
you to all right tell me what's the
maximum path sum of this tree this tree
is very small right if you identify the
root in this tree it's just the 42 node
right because it has no parent and i
also ask you for the leaves there's only
one leaf here and it's also the 42 right
because it has no children right so the
single node of 42 in this example is the
root and the leaf which means that the
maximal path sum would just be 42. cool
so i'm thinking about my base cases as
if they're their own inputs
nice and what you'll probably recognize
here is um in this scenario we're kind
of considering a base case that is not
about a null node right we will need at
least a separate base case that checks
if we have an actual leaf node and
that's very very inherent in given in
the problem right they say root to leaf
path
awesome so if that's the case i'm just
going to locate all of my leaf nodes in
this diagram and i know that they're
going to return
the values within them
so just plugging those in right
and now i can start reconstructing on my
higher level solutions right so given
this 11 node
what decision does this 11 node have to
make to compute its answer right so
let's root ourselves at this 11 node and
we have to consider
our left and right values right and so
if i root myself at 11 the 4 represents
my max path sum through my left subtree
and the right hand side too now
represents the max path sum through my
right subtree
since i want to maximize here the key is
to just choose between four and two
right i choose the bigger of them right
so four is bigger than 2 so i must use
the 4.
and what i do is i take that 4 and i add
my current value of 11 into it and that
gives me 15. and that would actually be
the answer for this subtree in other
words i can check for correctness right
now if i root myself at 11 i'm returning
15 to represent this path right i can
either do 11 plus 4 which is 15 or i can
do 11 plus 2 which is 13 right and that
13 is smaller so i won't prefer it here
cool so so far it seems like we're in
good shape
now let's take a look at another node we
need to evaluate let's look at this
three node
so it has a value on its right hand side
right it's receiving a one from its
right child but the left child doesn't
exist right if you want to be a little
more explicit we know that the left
child or three dot left is going to be a
null pointer all right so kind of plug
that in here
and here's where we should work in
possibly another base case sometimes
it's very natural just course correct as
we go
and so for a null node what should we
return
well we know that whenever we have a
null node it should never contribute to
our final answer we can kind of just
ignore it i guess but we want to make
sure that it's compatible with the rest
of our internal logic
so bear in mind in this problem i want
to take the maximum right
recall from our previous problem right
the min value problem we want to take
the minimum and so we made our null
nodes return infinity right because if i
want to find the minimum and my null
nodes return infinity by default i know
that infinity is never going to win a
comparison right because infinity is
very large and we just want to flip that
logic over here right so because in the
long run i want to find the maximum
i'll make my base case for the null
nodes return negative infinity
all right because i know negative
infinity is never going to win any
contest where we compare things looking
for the larger of the values right
so for this null node i'll plug in that
negative infinity
and now i should be able to do the same
business logic as before right so i'm
rooting myself at the three node and i
can look at the results i get from my
children right so between my two
children in my left
path i get a negative infinity or in my
right path i get a one and i choose the
maximum between them right
one is bigger than negative infinity so
i should use the one right and what i do
with that one is i add my current value
of three to it so three plus one gives
me four right and that makes some sense
because if i look at that small subtree
now rooted in three the biggest path
from root to leaf or sub root to leaf a
would indeed be a 4.
nice and now we have ourselves at the
ultimate root over here and i do that
similar comparison right
i check the bigger of my two children so
i'm going to keep the 15 but then i add
myself to it giving 20.
like we said before this 20 logically
represents this path of 5 plus 11 plus
4.
cool so there we have it
and if we want to take a look at the
complexity of this seems nothing unusual
so we're going to have n as the number
of nodes we're going to have o of n
runtime
because we're going to have to make a
call a recursive call that is for every
node within the tree and if i think
about any particular call we're going to
make for a node we're just going to do a
comparison right i just choose the
bigger of my two children so we're not
going to have any any loops within our
calls i believe
cool so it just seems to be of n time
and like we always say space complexity
is o n just due to the call stack
nice so let's go ahead and code this one
up and it should feel uh like a
combination of our previous tree sum
problems as well as some min value max
value logic
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this max root to leaf path sum
problem
so this is going to be a pretty
interesting tree problem
and we'll jump right into the code
please make sure you watch the approach
video before this because i think you
should be all primed up with the logic
that we want to implement here right
and so we'll start by doing this
recursively and i'd say that's probably
the best way to solve this one so i
think it's the only way i'll show you
and what i want to do is start with a
base case right so we said we want to
figure out our route to leaf paths so
our base case should be about whether i
have a leaf right so i'm going to go
ahead and check let's say if my root
left
is equal to null right
and
root right is equal to null right that's
a definition of a leaf
so if i have no left child and i have no
right child then i should return
the value stored at this node right so
root dot
val
nice
so again what we're kind of emphasizing
here is that base case catches a
scenario if we're at like four right we
have no children
nice
and we will need another base case in
the long run for now let's say we left
it like this right
so we said that in the context of
solving this one recursively the
decision we make at every node is i
choose the bigger result from my left
column my right call and then i add
myself to it right so i know i'm going
to do this recursively so i'm going to
call the same function and by now you
should be familiar with all right you
call your function on root left and also
root right
then i think about what those calls
return right they give me back the max
path some through my left subtree and
the max path sum through my right
subtree
i just want to choose the bigger results
between those two
so in the last video you saw me use the
math.min function here i'll use the
math.max function
and i know that these calls these
expressions evaluate to numbers so i can
actually just pass these guys in
inline so we'll just move this up like
that
so i'm finding the max between these two
results
and i'll go ahead and
call that we'll say
the
max
child
right
maybe i'll write this all online if you
prefer and then from there i just add
myself to that max child right so i'm
going to return
root.valit myself
plus
max
child and maybe i'll call that max child
path some
and that should be
it except for one thing we're forgetting
so take a moment see if you can read
between the lines here and what scenario
am i missing we did mention it in the
approach video
so can you spot what is not present here
and that's something i find
i do often right if i'm able to really
come up with a nice meaningful and
consistent picture then everything i
drew in the picture should translate
into some piece of code over here
just to give it a shot expect to fail
this one
see what we get
yeah and so we're getting an error
cannot read property left of null right
i'm filling on the very first example
so i'll tell you that this is caused by
an asymmetric node like this 4 over here
right this 4 has no
left child so imagine what would happen
in this instance right
so if we're evaluating this code we know
that our root is going to be this 4 node
and this if statement on line 10 is not
hit right because 4
is not a leaf right because it has a
right child it's right child is not null
so instead it's going to run into line
11 and it's going to try to execute max
path sum of root dot left root that left
is null and so when we actually evaluate
that call now we're saying root is null
and we're going to check null dot left
over here and that's going to break
right it's exactly the line that's
broken
and so in addition to this base case
right when we bottom out at a leaf node
what if we just end up
at a null node so if root is null
then we said that a good value to return
would be
negative infinity
right because i'm choosing to in the
long run do like maximal logic i want to
pick the max so if i choose a negative
infinity that won't interfere with any
of us taking a max
right because imagine that this thing
was negative infinity then i would just
prefer the right hand side if it was not
infinity right negative infinity that is
and so with that let's go ahead and give
this a go
cool and there we have a nice solution
for our max root to leave path sum
problem so notice how short the code is
by no means do i think this is simple
code though right at this point it's
okay if it feels a little tough
but do understand how we have some
familiar patterns right i still have
those two recursive calls right over
here
and we typically only vary in how we
take those recursive calls or the
results from them and combine them into
our higher level answer
so keep practicing this problem and i'll
catch you in the next one all right
programmers that wraps up our course on
the introduction to binary trees if you
want to explore this binary tree topic
or really any other data structure and
algorithm topic more deeply be sure to
head to structure.net where we have all
of these topics covered through tons of
problems where we have video
walkthroughs and illustrations for every
single problem i think you'll find this
especially useful if you're preparing
and really cramming for those technical
interviews thanks for watching and i'll
see you there